[Musique]
tu n'es pas le choix je suis coincé dans
cette réunion qui sert à rien mais j'ai
pas le choix c'est mon boss qui m'a
demandé d'être là je suis coincé dans ce
job qui ne me correspond pas mais j'ai
pas le choix faut bien que je paye mon
loyer
je suis coincé dans cette relation qui
n'a plus de sens mais j'ai pas le choix
faut protéger les enfants je vois bien
que la planète se dégrade mais j'ai pas
le choix faut bien que je me déplace
pour mon boulot et puis j'ai pas les
moyens d'acheter du bio
je n'ai pas le choix si vous êtes comme
moi on se sent drôlement impuissant à
chaque fois qu'on se le dise alors pour
sortir de ce sentiment je vous invite à
explorer l'hypothèse de choix formulée
par will shoot c'est l'hypothèse où on
ferait des choix même quand on a
l'impression de ne pas en faire et de
voir ce qui se passe prenons quelques
exemples
qui d'entre vous a choisi son job son
métier mais quelques-uns père
mon premier métier à moi c'était avocat
et très vite je me suis sentie enfermée
dans un métier qui ne me correspondait
pas j'avais fait du droit parce que mon
père voulait que je l'aide dans ses
affaires et je me sentais coincé à cause
de lui en formulant l'hypothèse du choix
j'ai pris conscience que en fait j'avais
fait le choix d'un métier pour avoir
enfin aux yeux de mon père l'importance
que j'avais jamais vu
c'est ce bénéfice là que je recherchais
sans m'en rendre compte
ma solution être avocat n'avait rien à
voir avec mon problème existait aux yeux
de mon père l'hypothèse du choix m'a
aidé à comprendre deux choses la
première c'est que je pouvais trouver
d'autres moyens pour exister aux yeux de
mon père qu'à travers un métier la
deuxième c'est qu'il y était pour rien
que j'étais seul responsable de mes
choix
avec cette prise de conscience
j'ai d'abord cessé de rejeter la faute
sur lui d'être victimes
et puis j'ai fait le choix de quitter ce
métier je suis sortie de l'impuissance
j'ai repris ma vie en main je suis
devenu libre et responsable choisir
sélectionnez s'orienter se déterminer
pour une préférence en fait nous
choisissons en permanence certaines
études nous disent même que nous faisons
jusqu'à 35 mille choix tous les jours
c'est énorme
et si nous choisissons c'est parce que
nous y gagnons quelque chose nous y
trouvons un bénéfice sauf que nous ne
sommes pas toujours conscients que nous
choisissons et que ce bénéfice
il est pas toujours conscient non plus
alors prenons un autre exemple la
manette pour ma part j'ai traversés j'ai
connu la maladie grave
ça m'est tombé dessus vous savez le truc
qu'on voit pas venir et qui vous met à
terre j'avais un grand sentiment
d'injustice et d'impuissance
sur le moment je me suis pas posé de
questions la situation était déjà
suffisamment difficile comme ça jallet
pam en rajouter et puis si je formule
l'hypothèse que j'ai peut-être choisi
quelque chose là dedans alors dans un
premier temps je peux me dire que j'ai
pas choisi d'être malade mais que je
peux choisir comment je réagis à la
maladie hélas déjà je sors de
l'impuissance et mon état d'esprit va
drôlement m'aider à faire face si je
pousserai hypothèse
un peu plus loin en me disant que
peut-être pour moi la maladie a pu être
un choix inconscient la shdm l'imaginer
je vous dis que vous vous dites qu'elle
est complètement fou peut-être vous avez
raison
enfin milan cette hypothèse après coup
par rapport à mon histoire
j'ai réalisé que d'être malade ça
m'avait permis d'obtenir beaucoup
d'attention de la part de mes proches et
pour quelqu'un qui a du mal à se sentir
important aux yeux des autres ça n'est
pas négligeable
c'est même un très beau bénéfice en
poussant l'exploration un peu plus loin
j'ai pris conscience qu'en mettant en
danger de mort ça m'avait permis de me
sentir vivante de tester au coeur de mes
cellules que j'étais en vie il avait
fallu que je sois malade pour me sentir
vivante comme s'il fallait se priver
d'un amour pour réaliser à quel point on
est aimé c'est complètement fou quand on
y pense
complètement absurde et pourtant dans
mon histoire
ça a beaucoup de sens
je n'ai pas à être malade pour me sentir
vivante
cette prise de conscience m'a amené à
choisir de me connecter directement à la
vie plutôt qu'à travers des choix qui me
sont néfastes
je choisi aujourd'hui de faire des
choses concrètes où je me sens
pleinement vivante comme d'être là
aujourd'hui devant vous
[Applaudissements]
l'hypothèse du choix a aussi changé mes
relations
effectivement si je retourne le
projecteur du choix sur l'autre alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe eh bien j'ai
devant moi un être capable un être qui
choisit qui choisit parce qu'ils y
trouvent un bénéfice conscient ou
inconscient et ça je ne peux pas le
juger
même si dans ma logique à moi je le
comprends pas le choix change
profondément le regard que je pose sur
l'autre il me permet de sortir du
jugement et de mettre en place des
relations tolérante le choix c'est
devenu la boussole de ma vie c'est ce
qui m'aide à trouver le sens orienté mon
action à m'impliquer
alors au lieu de nous dire j'ai pas le
choix si nous nous disions j'ai le choix
et si nous pouvions choisir beaucoup
plus que nous le niveau je dis non et si
nous avions le choix de notre job de nos
relations
le choix de nos actions pour la planète
jusqu'où choisissons nous de choisir
dans nos vies
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]